Continental Tire Coaches Corner
Jeff Van Gundy which on is momentarily
exclusive tired the Dan Patrick show no
matter where you are what's your drive
content designs tires for what you do
for more information visit Continental
Tire Calm Continental Tire for what you
do Jeff Van Gundy will be on the call
Game one Western Conference Finals that
starts Sunday 3:30 Eastern between the
Spurs and Moyers on the mothership Jeff
good morning thanks for joining us if I
didn't watch the game how would you
describe that to me what happened last
night unfathomable you know like the
combination of the Spurs playing such a
great road game and being dominant from
start to finish and the Rockets uh led
by Harden being a being passive really
at both ends of the floor and playing as
bad a game as they've played all year
that you know combination to me if you
would have said that before the game
without Leonard without Parker that
they're gonna win the game that would
have been a stretch but to dominate the
game I just couldn't have imagined that
when did you realize that what you were
seeing is what you were not expecting to
see well I think this really des started
the third quarter
any team can have a really bad half any
play great player can have a bad half
but I was most surprised about was the
start of the third quarter that the
Rockets after having you know halftime
didn't gather themselves and make a huge
emotional push to start that third
quarter you know something like you know
go on a six-o run they cut it to 13 give
yourself a chance you know cut it to 12
10 going into the fourth and please give
yourself that fighting chance there was
never a push there was never a feeling
like and their energy and effort is
becoming overwhelming they're they're
trying to overwhelm the Spurs
with some energy here never happened I
give San Antonio great credit you know
the post game Dan has sort of evaporated
from our game last night
San Antonio brought it back not only for
LaMarcus Aldridge but Jonathan Simmons
cutting off the post when the pass was
entered
they played old-school basketball
offensively last night and were
absolutely terrific and Aldridge
delivered when they needed a great
performance this isn't just a
coincidence that Hardin had a bad game
in a big moment he has not had a great
postseason career
what is it is there any explanation for
that well go back to the finals back
when it was Oklahoma City I didn't think
there was a compelling reason that you
could look and say he didn't play you
know great great in that series didn't
play very well at all over time you know
in game five here in this series you'd
have to say he did not play well at all
and then not to bounce back and have a
great game six there is to me no
explanation from a skill standpoint now
listen he didn't get any help either you
know Eric Gordon didn't play well Ryan
Anderson went went without a basket Lou
Williams was quiet and they missed a ton
of point blank shot at the rim
so listen harden didn't play well their
defense was bad but I think would be a
bit unfair to not also include the other
Rockets that didn't shoot well score
well or produce Continental Tire coaches
corner with Jeff Van Gundy here on the
Dan Patrick show if the MVP vote were
today finish that sentence well since
it's a regular season award I would vote
I would have voted for my choice would
have come down to harden Westbrook or
Kawhi Leonard I think why Leonard's the
best two-way player I think you can make
a case for him I would have voted Harden
slightly over Westbrook and Leonard
but you could have made a compelling
case for those three and LeBron James I
think most people still think he's the
best player in the game as as do I so
you can always make a compelling vote
for the best player in the game so I
would have voted harden but you know any
you know if you would have voted for any
of those four guys I couldn't argue with
you but it feels like we've moved on
from LeBron I'd said this during the
regular season I don't know if LeBron
wins another MVP and but I look at him
as the most valuable player in the NBA
if you needed to win a game he's the one
guy you want to have but I it's like
with Michael Jordan we moved wait you
know Barkley got it Karl Malone got it
but everybody knew who's going to win a
championship and that's the value now
that's not what you're supposed to
factor in with the voting but it felt
like we had heard the Jordan story and
we've moved on from it let's let's get
another fresh story in here it feels
like we've done that with LeBron James
not that Westbrook didn't deserve it or
Harden but if you had to win a game and
I gave you Harden Westbrook Kauai or
LeBron who you takin well you're taking
LeBron and and and maybe next you're
going to take two why Leonard because of
his two-way ability but I agree with you
I think I think the one thing that
worked against James this year in the
MVP voting was he didn't play like I
think it was 9 or 10 games yeah and then
secondarily you know Cleveland basically
checked out for a part of the regular
season and I think that was you know the
narrative about their season so I can
understand why people didn't vote for
him but I do think without question what
you said if you had to win one game you
know LeBron James is the guy right now
Kevin Durant may be next along with
Kawhi Leonard so it's it's an
interesting time in the NBA it's a
regular season award and you're right
though I think the media who vote for
these awards
sometimes get tired of just putting the
same name down over and over again the
Spurs against Golden State it feels like
we've already penciled this in it's
Cleveland and Golden State but give me a
compelling argument with the Spurs
against Golden State I don't have one
and I think anybody who acts like they
do is just making it up to try to make
it to sound better than it is San
Antonio is going to do what they do
they're going to play hard and they're
going to play smart and tough and poised
and discipline but the talent advantage
that Golden State has on every other
team in this league is as big inant
advantage as I've ever seen in the NBA
from the most talented team to the
second most talented team it's such a
huge advantage that to beat them four
times would require Golden State to play
very poorly have an injury an incident
and San Antonio to play so well and
shoot the ball from three and LaMarcus
Aldridge being great on a nightly basis
I just think there's too many things
that would have to go right to imagine
San Antonio not winning a game of course
they can win a game they're such a great
team but to win four games it's hard for
me to fathom explain to me how you can
have what I think is an evenly matched
series if not the Wizards being a little
bit better than the Celtics but these
games are like they're blowouts like how
does that happen where you play so good
and then you travel you know a thousand
not a couple of hundred miles and you
get smoked Jeff well Washington like you
know they got blown out right from the
start in Game five but they had actually
played two good games in Boston or had
great starts to those games in Boston
and just couldn't finish him you know
Boston in Game four had a great start in
Washington and then got overrun in that
third quarter
you know these massive runs like 20
so that's not a run that's like an
avalanche right so it's hard to explain
and but I still have enjoyed that series
I think it's in a hard-fought it's been
competitive you have teams that I would
agree with you the starting lineup of
Washington is a little bit better than
the starting lineup of Boston the depth
of Boston is better than Washington step
so it's been a compelling series
hard-fought series and enjoyable series
I think Washington will find a way to
win tonight
I just think Boston is going to win the
series even though they may not be uh
quite the level of talent as Washington
um how you doing with Mark Jackson you
guys are doing ok right you know Mark
Jackson and I we have no problems now
when you bring in the third wheel might
bring he's a divisive figure can I don't
know if it comes through in the
broadcast but he's very divisive he's
territorial and it's something that
we're going to have to address mark and
I after the season he's very selfish as
a play-by-play announcer it's all about
bringing and I understand that but you
and mark it's Herculean effort it's
pretty amazing what you guys are able to
accomplish well we're just being
overworked right now Dan as you can tell
like you know it's like you know our
producer Tim Corrigan is a relentless
taskmaster and it's something that
that's another thing that Mark and I are
going to have to go to upper management
about I'm sure they're going to be very
open to our suggestions well I think
that they should limit your minutes you
know I think that you should rest a
couple of times during games like take a
quarter off I think that's only fair no
back-to-backs
take a quarter off just you got to be
fresh when the final start man well mark
and Mike have accused me of taking many
people job I think I'm already on that
rap program thank you Jeff
tell tell the guy settle oh absolutely
Jeff Van Gundy from the mothership he'll
be on the call game one Western
Conference Finals sunday 3:30 Eastern
between the Spurs and lawyers on the
mothership the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience